him out and he just he just had fire in
his eye i can't explain it
coach rathman came up to me on the
sideline he said nahim is on fire and
i said leave him in you know i said
leave him we'll just give him a break
when he needs to break but let's
let's ride it um he was he came out
ready to play and yeah he always does
but every now and then you know how it
is you're in his own you got a little
extra juice and name had that today so
look great out there
that was colts coach frank reich talking
about the decision to trust our next
guest with the football over and over
and over again last night here he is one
day after his 24th birthday colts
running back naheem hines first of all
happy birthday second of all
congratulations on the great performance
last night third of all welcome to the
program how are you
well thank you for having me on i'm
honored uh had a great game so uh and a
great week so far so thank you for
having me on we've had a couple of great
performances recently two touchdowns in
two different games let's talk about
last night though and let's go bigger
picture since it was your birthday other
than giving yourself the gift of two
touchdowns what was the best present
nahim hines got for birthday number 24
uh
just to win a big divisional game uh you
know the colts we don't we don't have as
many primetime games other teams so the
fact that we got to play on primetime
against the divisional team and come out
with the win regardless of my
performance that's big to me you know
you know i love to play football nobody
plays to lose so uh really just happy to
go out there in a hard tough game and
divisional battle in the win
does that become a little bit of a chip
on the shoulder type thing in the locker
room hey we don't get respected we're
not in prime time why not us is that is
that a factor in getting yourself fired
up for a game like that
no not really uh
i know i i actually saw something on
twitter maybe like a couple months ago
that like we have like the lowest
percentage of like prime time games at
home but uh it's something actually
locker room we don't talk about at all
uh
their spectre chip on the shoulder we
don't really talk about that we got to
play who we have to play when it is so
if it's at one o'clock
monday tuesday wednesday thursday you
line the ball up
the colts are gonna be ready to play so
we really don't care about the prime
time and all that stuff
speaking of twitter i was creeping on
your page as the kids would say as you
would say since you're actually younger
than my son and i learned the term from
him
you have a picture
of the welcome to garner north carolina
sign and it says at the very top home of
2011 american idol winner scotty
mccreery when is that going to be taken
off and it's going to say home of nahim
hines
first off you did your research i
honestly like that's been my background
on twitter so long i i truthfully forgot
but
no it's it's scotty's town man uh scotty
even has the blue jackets commercials
and uh i don't have a bojangle to own or
a commercial so uh it's been great and
maybe we could split it one day but uh
really i don't really care about that i
just want to go there and represent the
talent of garner and make garner proud
you know it was impressive that you guys
were able to put a disappointing loss to
the ravens behind you so quickly
focus on a tough road game against a
division rival not let one loss become
two as chris sims likes to say
what was the key
in forgetting about what happened on
sunday and getting ready to go with only
a few days in between games oh the key
is simple we're competitors uh even
on sunday uh right after the loss you
know coach frank said what he had to say
then he did we start shifting gears on
thursdays prime time game first off it's
a prime time game like everybody we know
everybody's watching and it's a
divisional game so uh
there is there's not much you have to do
as a competitor and uh you know a member
of our team we you know we play titans
every year they know us well we know
them pretty well too so i mean losing to
the ravens on sunday and then come back
on thursday was a it wasn't that hard
just switch shifting gears you can't let
sunday effect thursday especially when
it's four days apart we came in on
monday we're ready to work and i think
we had a great week of preparation and
that's why we played well and you've got
this strange titan sandwich on the
schedule where it goes titans packers
titans bang bang bang do you like seeing
them again so quickly or would you
prefer to have more time in between
uh i think uh i think honestly our
schedule is very interesting because i
actually just saw schedules today and we
have the same thing with the texans i
think we play like right after we played
titans game we played the texans then
the uh
i think the raiders and the texans again
so i'm not sure who uh really set up our
schedule but i thought that was very
very interesting and uh
i'm not really sure you can really say
uh you know how we like you know what we
could possibly have or when we could
have it you just you play who's on you
play
who's you know like on the schedule that
we can shoot they have to get ready to
play us again too so you know it's gonna
be another competition and uh we're
gonna put this behind us and you know
like two weeks from now we're gonna
forget about this game we might try to
use it for motivation and energy but
that's gonna be a whole different game
we were talking a little bit before you
got started you said you're a little
sore but hey thursday night football you
get some break on the back end and you
know i've i've over the years
gotten mixed signals from players about
whether they don't like thursday
football or whether they do like it and
the guys who do like it focus on the
fact that we don't work as hard as a
normal practice week yeah and then when
the game's done
we got 10 days until the next one which
camp do you fall in
i don't even i'm not i'm truthfully not
sure which one i've fallen because uh
you know it's pretty cool not to
practice all week and you know have that
walk through but you know thursday
you're still feeling it but uh
especially with kova not being able to
go home it's been you know i'm still
going to be in any of the entire weekend
but uh
i'm not really sure which camp to fall
on i mean i you know
truthfully the thursday night games are
hard to play in because it's a quick
turnaround but it's prime time so you
know you get the best of both worlds
when you had something else going on
last night as displayed in the clip that
was played before we got started
coach rathman went to coach reich and
said this guy's got a fire in his eyes
there's there's you know he's he's got
it tonight what was it about you last
night could you feel that there was
something going on inside you that was
going to empower you to have the kind of
performance you did
uh i can't really say i had um
can't really say i had any look in my
eye or any fire just you know went out
there and made the mostly opportunity
you know every week that's how it is we
we go with the hot hand uh so one week
it may be me the next week maybe jordan
or jt so uh made the first two runs i
had out there were some uh pretty good
runs and i was like wow so there's
opportunity tonight and uh
really it's just going out there and
capitalizing on your opportunity uh
if if i'm in you got to be right on
every play and that's how coach raffin
teaches us and that's how you are we got
to be right fulfilled we gotta be right
protection right with our eyes and right
with our technique and discipline so uh
i tried to do that and uh they just rode
the high hand so i was happy the lord
allowed my body and you know allowed the
body in my body in the line just to hold
up the entire game and come out with a
win
take us inside the dynamic because it
has to be at least a little bit awkward
when you've got a couple of teammates at
the same position jonathan taylor and
jordan wilkins and everybody wants the
ball and yes you want to be a good
teammate and you understand you have
your role but you still want the ball
how do you guys balance that staying on
the same page your teammates we're
together but hey guys you know i kind of
want the ball
it's easy first off you know it it takes
a unique you know a unique group of guys
to even deal with something like that uh
first of all all of us are very like
we're very unselfish and selfless so we
want to do what's best for the team and
to help this team win so that's the
first thing and then really after that
it's uh
this is how it works we just have to you
know be ready and you have to stay race
you don't get ready so you have to get
ready sometimes even in practice we may
not even know who the hot hand is it
just sometimes you could practice
something all week and then you may or
may not be in so it's really just you
know just having the discipline and you
know having the mental you know
stability to stay in there and i think
with that it's just a really really big
for us just to keep pushing and keep
going forward because we don't know who
the high hand is going to be but we know
when we're playing well this office is
moving we got play action passes behind
it and you know we got a bunch of great
receivers out wide who can make plays
too
against the lions you scored a couple of
touchdowns and you did some pretty
impressive gymnastics moves to celebrate
i'm sure you've been asked about that
more times than you care to discuss but
where does that come from that ability
and when did you realize that you had it
i realized that probably when i was
about 11 or 12 years old um i used to
flip on the trampoline a lot and a lot
of flips i learned on the trampoline i
just had the uh
you know i had the courage to try them
on the ground because i you know i
thought i had the uh the air and the
height to do it and uh those tricks i've
been doing for like
10 or 10 or 12 years so they've been
they've been in them they've been in my
bag of tricks for a while so you know
when you've had that many reps of it you
can just go out there with a helmet and
i just throw it and just hope you get
around so uh really excited don't know
if it's going to come anymore any less
this this is kind of how like the high
end is with the colts running back it's
just how you feeling that day so last
night you weren't feeling it
i was tired and uh some of the
touchdowns i mean i'm not just going to
do a uh round off full and a two-yard
touchdown
having some real explosive plays you
know on detroit lines you know i had to
spin move and it was a really good spin
move and i knew it was time but you know
if i'm that close to the goal line i'm
not doing any flips where i can't not
celebrate my teammates i always want to
celebrate my teammates i'm going to be
dancing on the camera and doing stuff on
my teammates sitting there watching i'll
celebrate with them earlier today on our
morning show peter king said he saw some
le'veon bell in you who who do you try
to emulate when you play
uh
that everybody doesn't really say i try
to emulate anybody i watch a lot of film
and i see a lot of great running backs i
love watching le'veon even watching
marlon mack the past two or three years
she's helped me uh you know learn to set
up blocks and uh learn things about the
nuances of you know running the ball and
uh growing up i used to love barry
sanders and award done so uh
it's it's been you know i've watched a
lot of great running backs and i even
darren sproles so really just
probably a mosh pit of guys i love to
watch
you've been uh with the colts now this
is your third season fourth round pick
out of nc state in 2018 how has your
game improved the most since you've been
in the nfl uh i think just really just
the confidence uh you know at first
maybe i didn't see you know see
something
and uh go with it all the way but i
think it just comes with the reps and
just the preparation that i have i think
i've spent a lot of time it's preparing
for every moment and visual
visualization has been really big for me
i've visualized a lot of plays before
they happen visualize a lot of things
that could possibly go right or wrong in
the play so when they come to me you
know uh it's not like a surprise even uh
the detroit the detroit uh the first
detroit uh touchdown i had uh the spin
move and practice already visualized and
i already knew i was gonna have to make
some guy miss i actually thought i was
gonna make two guys missing or two i
threw the block and uh it was only one
guy it was even a better play because it
was a lot it was less than i expected so
uh if you prepare for the worse you can
expect the best
you guys have some great players on your
team on both sides of the ball and
you've got some just football players
guys that are rough and tough and go out
and do what needs to be done so let me
give you this hypothetical
you're heading down a dark alley and you
know that there's some bad guys down
there that that mean you potential harm
physically give me three teammates you
want to take with you down that alley
quinn nelson deforest buckner
uh
big grove grover stewart there you go
the bodyguard right there yeah and and
now let me flip it around let's just
have a little fun give me one guy you've
encountered from another team during
your uh time in the nfl that you
wouldn't want to encounter down that
dark alley
sure there's a there's a lot there's a
lot of guys
fletcher cox elodie nada i mean there's
a lot of great guys i played
what's the first thing that comes to
mind when you think that you know you've
got this game against the packers the
green bay packers coming up
at 4 25 eastern a big spot on a sunday
afternoon what's your first thought
aaron rodgers uh it's gonna be a big
stage and i watched a lot of first takes
so i could just think about you know
stephen a smith saying he's a bad bad
man
and uh i think about the uh the
challenging opportunity we're both
playing great football there's a great
we have a great defense they have a
great offense so something has to give
and offensively speaking you know we
have to go out there and you know try to
keep 12 off the field and you know
manage the clock and play a great great
sound game and not give them
opportunities
well nahim we congratulate you on your
incredible performances so far this year
happy birthday all the best hopefully
get a little rest this weekend and get
ready to go for the packers next week
yes sir and uh thank you for having me
on it's an honor
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports